it's great to be here
the title of this talk is somewhat
aspirational it's sort of more what we
want to do as opposed to what we have
done
so if you don't like why i'm by himself
if you don't like what we're doing
that's terrific because then you can
come and help us do it better
his joint work with many many people uh
so the basic problem is uh decision
making at scale that's
essentially what democracy is you're
making a decision at scale and the
question is
can we do it differently now or should
we do it differently now now that we
have all these internet enabled
systems so if you have a simple problem
like
is it obama or romney it's very easy you
can just do a simple poll
but suppose you have a more complex
decision how can we cut the us budget
deficit
and you ask that question on any blog
let's say you go to a blog and you say
well
how do we cut the the us deficit
and someone is going to start calling
come in someone else is going to call
you
is going to start calling you like
a blood sucking capitalist someone will
sort of start to bring that death panels
in and very soon they'll be
shouting at each other and i can
guarantee that a coherent solution to
the u.s budget deficit is not going to
emerge
so the question is how can we make
decisions at scale in the face of
polarization and extreme opinions
free from discussion boards often
degenerate into vitriol
and so we need more structured modes of
interaction with provable properties and
so so that's what we're trying to
develop we've had some successes on the
ground we did a large uh
pilot in the city of vallejo this month
last month
which was interesting because vallejo is
a city that emerged from bankruptcy
so trying to figure out how to make
decisions as a city is something that's
uh
part of the healing process
so as a warm-up exam and so so once
again
uh just to emphasize this again
what you're going to see is more like
sausage being made so the stock is
mostly aspirational
we have various pieces and each of these
pieces is interesting in its own
regard and trying to fit them together
into sort of some sort of a seamless
decision-making scale platform is i
don't think we are very close to it yet
so here's a one more example it's one of
those examples where we have
a mode of interaction that we really
really like but we haven't been able to
prove much about it
so let me just describe the the mode of
interaction so this is at this point
this is more of an open problem
so normally people put open problems at
the end i thought let me put one in the
beginning
so the example is suppose you have many
many users many many proposals
you want to do something completely
unstructured and the unsuccessful thing
could be how should we organize this hci
seminar
or what should ici group do next year it
could be anything
a user can make as many proposals to
solve a complex problem as she likes
like 1 2
3 100. each user has only one word
she can change her vote as often as she
likes
and a proposal that ends up with
keywords get k-squared tickets to a
lottery
so this is a fairly simple it's a fairly
simple game
so what does this go what does this game
do it rewards consensus building
so for example imagine that a b and c
have some preferences and their
preferences happen to be very close to
each other
and so they all of them have one ticket
to the lottery if they
come to a compromised position if all
three of them vote on the same proposal
then together they'll have nine tickets
to the lottery as opposed to three
difficult lottery
so in our simulations in our small
experiments this works very well
and the question and the open problem is
can we characterize the nash equilibrium
of this game
and to begin with can we do it just for
grading
i'm going to explain what i mean just
for grading so
so this is an example of a structured
interaction
and so the structure here is that you're
voting for something
in general if you just allow if you
allow people to vote for something
and you do majority rule then there's
several problems with the majority rule
first of all the minority is not
empowered
so if sixty percent of people think one
thing or the remaining forty percent
thing is completely irrelevant
that doesn't happen in this game if
sixty percent of the people are here and
forty percent are there
those forty percent still have a small
chance of their ideas coming up
then what if there's no majority
in this case if the 30 of the people who
really believe in one proposal
and everyone else is all over the place
then those 30 of the people are almost
guaranteed to win
so imagine you have a population of a
million people 300 000 of them strongly
believe this is the right thing to do
everyone else can't agree among
themselves right when this when you when
you
when you take the square those 300 000
people are almost guaranteed to win
so the way we tested this was in the
form of a small game
and the game is only called the grading
consensus game
and in this game what we ask students to
do is to decide how to allocate
weights to the first three homeworks and
the midterm of a class
so students are already done like
they've already done the three homework
they've already in the midterm
and the question is how do you assign
how do you decide what the weightage of
each of these things is
and the total weight is fixed will be 50
percent is students could propose
whatever they want okay
so so that's the that's where the
non-structure or the complexity of the
problem comes in
so somehow the goal is to not have to
model the problem completely in its
whole generality
so for each of these problems we don't
want to go and do something separate for
grading
something separate from budgeting right
so can we have something more general so
the students can propose whatever they
want
and then they can go and change their
votes as often as they want and the game
ended at some point
and then each proposal consists of four
values corresponding the weight for each
assignment and the exam in the final
gate the sum to 50
and for each proposal you can view the
number of current votes on it and its
current probability of winning
and at the end so we run this lottery at
some point the game ends and we run this
lottery
no so so right so right now right away
as soon as you define this mode of
interaction
you immediately get into like the first
algorithmic problem there
how do you decide when to end yeah how
do you visualize the other existing
proposals and
the amount of words they all currently
have
um you just show them everything it's
the full information
popularity you can show them it's a full
information game
so i forgot the password
but that's our information game so when
you get in you see all the problems that
have been made
you see all the votes on every proposal
you see the chances of
every proposal winning so we don't even
expect to do the quadratic thing and
then take
divide the ratio we are told what your
current expected score is because we
know your grade
and you're told what your score would be
if you move somewhere else
expect this score so every it's a full
information game there's
nothing being hidden from anyone so it's
not like one of those games where we
sort of
uh we really want to mimic this
democratic process right we want people
to have all the information we're not
trying to hide anything from anyone
and so it worked well uh everyone did
best response
a creal clear majority emerged the
majority that emerged was in the best
interest of
the the people who voted for that and uh
so the game was actually
as an expert was very successful the
instructor hated it
because because the outcome was all the
word all the way to the first homework
and nothing on homework 2 3 or the
midterm
were you the instructor no this is
ramesh let me show the instinct
so so this is an example of what i mean
by structured interaction okay so that's
the kind of thing we're shooting for
we're shooting we ultimately do want to
build these systems we do want to deploy
them in practice
i'm going to show you some example
deployments but you want to do more than
that we want to understand
exactly what the systems are are we are
we confidently extracting the right
thing
can we analyze uh
what the what the behavior of the system
is going to be at scale and mostly
how do we cope with the fact that when
you go to vote you're voting on a small
number of things
you're typically voting among three
candidates for president
in in in democratic the same making you
want to get to the point where everyone
is an opinion
so if a million voters you also have a
million proposals
and so in that in that kind of a setting
can you still make decisions
in some systematic uh formal fashion
so here's the first uh technical thing
i'm gonna i'm not gonna describe the
technical part in too much detail i'm
gonna just show you an example of how
the technical patterns are being very
useful
it's uh crowdsourcing of participatory
democracy so in particular democracy
what happens is
this is a picture that david found is
this very appropriate
normally think of democracy as you're
going to go and you're going to elect a
set of representatives
and those apprentices are actually going
to go and make a decision but what if
you wanted to make decisions directly as
a community so what do you want to just
like all of you
if you're in a city and that 20 000 of
you could all 20
000 of you collected with brainstorm one
of the right thing for the city to do is
and then collectively decide on a course
of action
that's a little bit different from the
population system and the population
system
essentially is true that you're directly
voting on something but what you're
working on is just two or three things
which have still been set by a committee
somewhere
so participating democracy is a process
emphasizing the role of citizen
involvement
in political decision making and so
what we would like to do in this setting
is we would like to have the
have a process which allows us to get to
some nice social choice function so what
what does it mean
imagine you have all these proposals
imagine you have these three voters
and these three voters rank all the
proposals in some order
so we are given the first one ranks as
one two three four five six the second
one does the same thing
the third one has a different ranking
so social choice function is something
that takes all these rankings
and outputs a single ranking so that's
that's the typical definition of a
social choice function
now the problem so that's the typical
way in which people have thought of
socialized functions
the problem of course is when you have
as many proposals
as you have voters or when you have like
dozens of proposals you have like 100
proposals or 10 000 purposes
then it's unreasonable to expect any
user to come up with a full ranking
of all the proposals and so what you
would like to do instead
is to elicit their preferences without
asking them to do a full ranking
and the way you would like to do this
for example could be just ask them to
make a comparison
so you could just ask each user to do a
small set of comparisons
and the question then becomes can we
find the output ranking assume there's a
fix there's an output ranking that we'd
like to get
uh which is determined by the social
choice function we want to implement
can we find it with a small number of
comparisons
and the many negative theoretical
results so for example
the main one is kunis and send home we
said that if you have m proposals and
n voters and you want to extract what's
called the border rule
and so the border rule just says
if you arrange everyone if you take all
the rankings and you look at any
proposal
and look at his average rank in all
these proposals that's your border rank
so your border rank is just the average
rank that you have in
the ranking made by every voter so it's
idea clear you have a bunch of proposals
your bunch of voters
each voter is imagine each voter is
ranking all the proposals
then the average rank of a proposal
across all the voters
is the border rank of that proposal
so so the question is you want to
extract this border rank how many
comparisons do you actually need to make
and there's a lower bound by connecting
sandom which says that you really need
n times m times log m comparisons
now that's not a big deal if m the
number of proposals is small
because n times m times log n really
means that any individual only has to
make m log in comparisons
so if m is small like m is like 5 or 6
it's ok you can just ask them to make 10
comparisons and you're done
but what if ms has to become 20 30 40 50
80 right
even around 20 it starts to become very
hard to expect people to rank
20 things uh comple produce a full range
list of 20 things
and so what we
observed was that even though these
things are
sorry so you need n times m times log m
to do border
you need n times i'm going to do
condorcet and conversa is a very nice
concept a conducive winner
of a word is somebody is a proposal who
would beat every other proposal in a
pairwise word
so if there's condo7 let's say let's say
you are the conducive winner
that means that there's an election
between you and any one other person
you're going to win
so conversative winners are very good
when they exit conversations are like
the right
is the right notion of a winner except
that it may not always exist
so there exist situations when a will
beat b b will be c
c will be a if you have a pairwise
election
so whereas border ranking is always well
defined
so if a conversation exists then uh
cornelia and sandum said that you cannot
extract
a controversial even if it exists using
less than n times some comparisons and
again that's going to be too much
yes assuming
that it's easier to do m
pairwise comparisons than to rank and
things
um well it's a negative result
so saying that you need to do at least
that many comparisons
which really essentially says that you
might as well just ask me to do a full
line
right right because if you take any
individual because the amount of work
any individual is doing is m log m
in m logging comparisons you can sort
so saying that you need m login
comparisons
per user is essentially the same as
saying that there's nothing you can do
using comparisons
you might as well ask users to do a full
ranking yeah
so so you're not really getting anything
by comparisons uh if you're looking for
exact results
but what we showed was that if we want
to approximate the outing
output ranking with a small number of
comparisons so we happy to say okay well
we don't really want an exact answer
we are happy if we get an approximate
ranking then some
somehow suddenly it turns out that you
can do much better the factor of n goes
away completely
so you only need m over epsilon squared
log m over delta
uh comparisons i'm going to explain what
epsilon and delta are in a few seconds
but if you were to ignore epsilon
log m and log of one over delta which is
what you would do if you take like any
algorithms class then you're left with
just
m okay and so m is the number of
proposals
so which means that the average number
of uh
comparisons that a voter has to do is
essentially going to zero
so that's the kind of thing which if if
m is comparable sorry if m is comparable
to n then the average number of
components of water has to do is still
remains small
so that's the kind of protocol that
could potentially scale to having
many many proposals and many many users
so yes defining
the border winner let s of x is the
number of comparisons one
by a particular proposal x a border
winner
is just the one that maximizes
s of x saying that you're looking for
saying that you're looking for someone
with the highest bold account
it's the same as you're looking for
someone with the highest average rank
which is the same as maximizing someone
maximize the person who's going to win
the highest number of comparisons
if all the components are going to
actually get made
so the border winner is just the one
that wins the most comparisons and an
epsilon border winner is someone who
means at least one minus epsilon as many
comparisons
and so if we randomly sample comparisons
we just ask people to randomly
uh compare different things then
the algorithmic board is just you pick
two things at random you show them to a
voter
the voter sort of chooses one versus the
other then you
go to another voter you pick another
random set of two things you ask them to
compare those
so there's no correlation to ask a voter
to compare two things you are picking
the two things you are comparing
completely at random
and so the theorem is that order m over
epsilon squared log of m over delta
comparisons
are sufficient to find an epsilon border
winner with probability at least one
minus delta
so that gives you some hope that you can
actually scale this this comparison
based system
to a situation where the number of
proposals and the number of people are
comparable to each other
this is independent of n and so if m is
less than n then this is like
log n comparisons person not m log n
comparisons person but login comparisons
per person
so he took this idea and we applied it
to an experiment in finland where
we wanted to crowdsource their off-road
traffic law
so a big chunk of finland is under ice
for a big chunk of the year
so you wouldn't imagine this to be true
but where you can drive your snowmobiles
is a hot button political issue in
finland much the same
like in in the areas around yellowstone
in the u.s
and so our collaborator
tanya itamurto had already extracted
a bunch of proposals made by
a bunch of islamic enthusiasts
environmentalists
landowners in finland and then we ran a
comparison based process
also a ranking based process we said we
just asked people to randomly compare
different things
like location of routes what would be
the best way to situate slow mobile
routes
and we just completely randomly picked
two things out and give it to them
and we asked them to compare one idea
could be
undeveloped land beyond residential area
should be made available as free riding
zones
the other should be there should be more
routes in the eastern and northern parts
of finland
and it's a bit of an unfair thing to do
it's like a very appreciative comparison
but we just like pick two things in
random
i was going to compare them and they
said they
they said either this is better or
that's better
we also occasionally ask them to rate
things he said like here's an idea give
it a rating between one to five stars
as it turns out it worked very well so
first of all
i am not going to get into the detail of
this plot except to show that it exists
that whatever i was saying about
extracting epsilon approximation
actually works in practice
the you can plot as you get more and
more verse you can see how what your
approximation of the border score is
and you see it decreasing pretty much
around the formula that we we had proved
but equally interestingly what we found
was that since we also have these
ratings
one thing that we found was that
whenever we go to talk to so even when
we go and talk to a city
or a government and we say we want to do
this kind of a crowd-sourced law for you
the first thing they say is well the
first thing that they want
is that they want these results
segregated by demographics
they how don't understand work
how did black's word uh how did whites
what how did it how did f
someone with a college education work
and so
what we realized is all of that's
interesting right what's more
interesting
this is completely forget all of that
and what we did was we just looked at
people's ratings
and based on that we established a
similarity function between people just
based on how they're voting
and so so if for example
uh you and i would in very similar ways
then we'll be sort of
then our score will be higher and based
on that we clustered all the users
and we clustered all the users we found
that there's a majority component out
there and there's a minority component
out here it's a very clear it's a very
clear cluster
and the majority voted one way but the
majority had a very clear vote i mean
this is a very clear winner by the
majority
and the minority voted another way okay
and it's
a very clear winner in the in the
minority and these kinds of things are
very
this kind of minority majority opinion
is very hard to extract without this
kind of unsupervised clustering
and the reason is when you're carving
things out by demographics
you're sort of imposing your own notion
of what a minority is
you might you might believe that this
this particular segment of society is a
minority
right whereas uh what might actually
happen on the ground is very different
so for example
the minority cluster here is women
environmentalists and landowners and
there's no way you would have thought of
that as a minority cluster right because
like
half the people are women and then on
top of that you're adding landowners so
how could that be a minority
but especially especially because we are
doing these things
especially as we build these systems
which are going to be primarily on the
internet
and they're going to be more
increasingly responding driven somehow
your old notions of minority which is
let's take a demographic demographic cut
and try to define minorities that
minorities by a demographic cut
become quite redundant because the
people who would
the people who would vote on this
platform
are people who really care about the
issue and maybe snowmobile users care
more about the issue then
and maybe someone will use us all may
all men and those kinds of things are
very hard to know
before the fact so one thing to remember
as we as we
do more and more of these
respondent-driven crowd-sourced
uh democratic processes is that we have
to have
instead of just targeting them by old
notions of demographics we have to look
at the data
and then target them according to how
they and then cluster them going to how
they work so the other
the other thing that became that was
very exciting and the reason i wanted to
describe this
board account as well it turned out to
be really useful in something else that
we
want to do and that's participatory
budgeting yeah
is um a problem in practice though so
privacy around
so there might be a big problem if you
want to understand
if you want to associate
personally identifiable data with a node
in the network
so that's something we could do in this
case because we had sort of done an
experiment right but just knowing the
way people voted
i'm not seeing a big privacy concern
there so if there's no if there's no
connection between an
identity and your vote
then it seems like then it seems like uh
so then what you essentially the the
data that we need to do this clustering
is just the entire set of words you made
it has to have no personally
identifiable
identifiable information about you
is it just that you want to identify a
minority or do you want to comment
in this case we went a little bit
further and we said the minorities were
sort of these demographic groups
but in general there's no reason to do
it so for example if you think of some
of these processes are mandatory
in the sense that they're binding the
outcome that comes from them is binding
on the city or binding on the state
this particular crowdsource process was
advisory
so especially if you're running an
advisory process it's very important to
go to them and say well
instead of just saying well this is the
guy that won it's very
it's much more informative going to say
this is the guy that won but by the way
there was a clear minority of say 25 000
people
who thought in this other way and just
that
that sort of that data driven cut on on
minorities is uh
what what becomes essential as you start
to do these things
not in a way in which you're calling
everybody or everybody is going to a
poll but where people can go to internet
site involved
yeah do you have any do you get any
pushback
concerned about control it's like we can
tell you
hey with you know relatively high
probability
we'll get you the right answer um when
it's a very high stakes decision like
this do people ever
chafe i just say like oh we'd rather do
the
the slower the more boring thing that
requires more work
that people have to understand what's
happening so the pushback that we get is
not so much around uncertainty
because people sort of already
understand with all this polling people
already understand it's like margin of
errors and so on
the big question that we get is if if
you're running a process it should be
clear to someone
how their vote could potentially change
the outcome
so for example if you're doing uh
when you're voting in a for obama versus
romney
it's very clear one you vote and obama's
tally goes up by one
romney's tele doesn't go up by one if it
is a comparison between
candidate x and candidate y and then
it's going to go into some kind of a
board account
then it's not transparent to the the
water what their word really meant
and that's been a bigger pushback for us
than the uncertainty in the process
that kind of thing that makes them feel
more comfortable i think there's even
better interfaces for which we need a
lot of help
so for example the kind of so
so the kind of interface i'm not
describing it in the stock because
we don't have it deployed anywhere yet
but the kind of interface that i think
will ultimately need to build
is some sort of like an espn lag
interface so i don't know if you have
seen an espn they do is voting
and in espn there is this voting where
they say rank all the teams
and you have like 30 slots and you can
go and put whatever team you want in
whatever slot you want to fill all the
slots you can stop whatever you want
but even though the exact formula
might not get disclosed by espn now the
exact formula might be some complex
weighted thing
just the fact that you know that this is
ranking that you're submitting
makes people say well i'm submitting a
ranking and the ranking is going to
affect and then ultimately the ranking
is going to come out
and so at that point people are i i
don't know maybe the psychologist in the
audience who know what the difference
between that and comparison system
because they're both opaque formulas but
the fact that he submitted a ranking
and the output is going to be a ranking
somehow makes users comfortable
feel like they understand how their word
is going to affect things but when
they're doing a comparison and the
output is going to be a ranking then
they're a bit more
it's more nebulous than them
so the next thing i want to talk about
is participatory budgeting and knapsack
voting
uh there's a big nationwide push now for
participating budgeting the
the white house is uh uh made a
proclamation last year saying that they
want to see more participatory budgeting
in more cities
and so what happens in participatory
budgeting
is that uh in any city or any community
a certain amount of money gets set aside
and then the citizens of that community
or the residents of the community would
come together
they would decide on 15 or 20 or 50 or
proposals to put on the ballot and then
there would be a city-wide election
and whatever projects win would
essentially get assigned that money
and residents love it
politicians also love it because a lot
of decisions for
which we're up where the only
if if you're trying to sort of decide
whether to put a fountain in this park
or a bench on that bus stop
it's not like the politician has any
vested partisan interests and it's not
like the democrat is going to say do
this that will be saying
that let's do that and so it's not it's
not something out where
it's not it's not non-political decision
so politicians love doing this kind of
stuff for non-political decisions right
there's no there's no chance of them
being of anyone
there's no chance of anyone being called
partisan because you put
a fountain here as opposed to a bench
there
and when they decide they get criticized
when the community decides the community
decided right it's nothing to do with
them
so it's something which actually
politicians actually like and so the way
they do it is by approval voting
uh the voting itself is approval voting
what that means is every voter chooses k
projects for a fixed k and the project
that gets the most words getting gets
implemented
and so our tool was used as a digital
voting platform in chicago's 49th world
and in vallejo
i'll just show you a quick demo
so first of all so this is sort of
probably more of an sci like thing right
so what what this so the way they are in
this process is that they have a paper
ballot and this digital
ballot and voters can choose to use
whichever one they want
so we are constrained to do have the
same kind of format as the paper valid
but you can already see that this is
much more informative in the paper
ballot
so for example they have street
resurfacing sidewalk repairs and street
lighting
and so if you click on a street
resurfacing option a map pops up right
on the map you can see exactly which
streaks are getting resurfaced
and so this goes to one point one
pushback against digital tools at least
in the in
the democracy space is that there's a
digital divide
and what we're trying to tell cities and
foundations and whoever listens to us
is that it's not it's not a digital
divide it's a digital bridge
so the goal is that tools like this
should reduce the literacy device the
real divide is a literacy divide
that if you can't if you don't know how
to read
then our claim is that this kind of an
interface or if you're not a proficient
reader
this kind of an interface is an easier
way for you to vote than to have all
that information about exactly
these three street names sort of uh
presented to you in an order saying
if you vote for 10 percent this street
gets the surface if you're 20 this other
state also gets resurfaced
so this is one big challenge trying to
convince
cities and states that these tools are
not going to decrease
it's not going to sort of make the
literacy divide worse
then so as you're voting you can see you
can see what you're voting on
and as you can see this is an approval
vote you can select up to four things
you can also select how much money you
want to spend on
on each on on the street resurfacing
but there's no connection between how
much money you are spending
and what you are voting on so how much
there's no connection between uh there's
no restriction on how much money
you're allowed to spend it's only like
how many projects you're allowed to
choose
and so that leads us to one big problem
with the approval voting
which is that there's no recognition of
trade-offs
so there's no the so we feel it's the
wrong question to ask is it better to
build a
build a fountain in a park or fill a
pothole on a street
because it's not clear how you would
answer that question that's not the way
we make decisions in our life
the right question tons ask is is it
better to build a fountain for 10k
or fill a portal for 1k and that's when
we can all make these value for money
decisions that we that we're used to
making in our own life right
so approval voting doesn't actually
force anyone to recognize any trade-offs
because you can vote for whichever four
projects you want and you don't have to
recognize that some of them might be
more expensive than others
and then the exchange incentives so
imagine you go to a race
and there's a horse that you really
really really want to win that's your
favorite horse
you also have insider information
knowing that horse is actually going to
win
so that's the horse you who's your
favorite and you know is going to win
would you ever bet on anyone else and
the answer is no there's no incentive
for you to vote
better than anyone else but that can
happen with approval voting
so there can there exist cases where a
voter should vote for a o
over b if a self-interest voter should
vote for a over b
even if she prefers b and b is winning
and that's a this is a sort of bizarre
kind of incentive that gets set up and
one way of thinking about this is
you know you have you can vote on two
things or you can let's say you can only
vote on one thing
and you know medicare is winning anyway
so why vote for medicare let's forget
about medicare let's go and vote for
something else
so those kinds of exchange incentives
make this make it very non-obvious what
it really means to aggregate
uh how to aggregate these words
and then also we don't feel as wrong is
the right question
so in fact we feel like all these
participatory budget all budgets are
like knapsack
and knapsack processes right so in a
nasdaq problem you are given a nav sag
it is a fixed capacity and you're given
a bunch of goods each good has a value
and a size and you want to pack as much
value into your knapsack without
exceeding the capacity okay
that's the standard knapsack problem all
budget problems except the federal
except the federal budget are knapsack
voting
because in states for example in
california you cannot exceed the revenue
that you have
in cities like san francisco you cannot
even have revenue measures
as part of the budget so if san revenue
it has to be a separate process the
budget is sort of like a fixed amount of
money
you're trying to pack something into it
all the participatory budgeting
processes that cities have run that we
know of have a fixed part of money that
we're putting things into
so all of these are like really like
knapsack boards uh
was the right way to solve an abstract
word a knapsack problem was the optimum
solution to an abstract problem
sorry suppose you need to worry about
the edge effect so it's mph effect
because you can't use things
fractionally
so the right thing to do is to arrange
your items
in decreasing order of value
per pound okay and then
just pick start picking from the top of
the pile and dumping them into your
knapsack until your knapsack becomes
full
and that ends up being the optimum
solution an abstract problem
so so immediately this budgeting problem
now is reduced to a ranking problem
and the ranking problem is where you're
not ranking by value and you're not
ranking by money you're ranking by value
for money
and so that's the next thing we did
so for example this is not this is not a
part of the ballot
what i showed you before was the actual
ballot that was used by chicago
and a similar ballot was used by valho
last month
what i'm showing you now is an interface
is a is an experiment that we do
so after people are done with their
actual ballot we ask them to play around
as a survey like
like an irb approved survey and we ask
them which project gives the best value
for the money
and people have a very hard time
assigning value to these kinds of things
it's very hard to say what's the value
to the community for it from replacing
the carpet
i mean no nobody knows what that value
is but people find it very easy to make
these value for money comparisons
so that's something we've consistently
found that actually takes people less
time to breeze through these value for
money comparisons
then it does for them to choose four
things that they want to vote on
so we're not asking them what the value
of a carpet is about the value for the
fountain
is we're telling what the costs are and
then we say which of these projects
gives better value of money
to the valho community or the chicago
community
and the claim is because the optimum
solution is an abstract problem is to
pick things in decreasing order of value
for money if we can extract that
societal ranking or value for money then
we have an optimum solution in an upside
problem
so so in addition we get some other nice
properties
which so we have make some some progress
on strategy-proofness
so you want to make sure that at least
this kind of this bizarre thing doesn't
happen
that this voter this
this voter prefers b and b is winning
but she votes for it so that that's
that's the this is a very minimum kind
of bizarre behavior you want to
eliminate
and something which doesn't have that
behavior where if you prefer something
and something is winning you will vote
for it
that's what we call weak strategy
proofness
so you're not always going to be
truthful but when
the thing that you prefer is already
winning you're going to be truthful
and so the basic idea of trying to get
strategy proofness
is to make voters recognize trade-offs
so we ask users to submit an entire
budget
so instead of asking them to choose four
proposals
four projects which may or may not add
up to which may exceed the budget which
will be
under the budget we ask them for an
entire solution to an abstract problem
so we say just make the whole budget
tell us exactly what what you'll pick
without exceeding a million dollars
which is which is the
budget amount then the best response by
a user to everyone else's word is weekly
strategy proof
if something is winning and you want it
to win you will vote for it
a little bit if i know that something is
going to get funded no matter what i do
then why not included the why included
in my budget i know it's going to happen
so i can
i can sort of spend my special interest
money on other stuff
because you have to give an entire
solution
so you might say well i want i want this
other thing to win
so you might vote for it but that entire
thing can't be the whole of the knapsack
so let's say i want i want a million
dollars to go to medicare and i want a
million dollars to go to
let's say gun control yeah let's say
drug enforcement
i really really like medicare but i know
that if i don't vote for drug
enforcement it's not going to win
so i might vote for drug enforcement but
i have to fill the whole knapsack
they're two million dollars
so even after i work for drug
enforcement there's still money left to
fill
so might as well also vote for the thing
that i really like which is medicare
like i only care about drug enforcement
like that's the one thing that i care
about this
in this election why not if that's the
only thing you care about this isn't
applied to you
so we're not trying to do social
engineering in the sense we don't
whatever you believe is ground truth
what you care about is what you care
about
when you say strategy proof you're not
saying we're not saying you have to
somehow think about everybody else
all we are saying is if if you want
something to win and that thing is
winning
then you shouldn't vote against it
so maybe so let's say
let's say let's say you can listen
let's say your nasa capacity is 2
and currently medicare is winning
and
gun control is winning
now for you what your preferences are
medicare
and drug enforcement
if you can only vote for one thing you
might go and vote for drug enforcement
even though you like medicare better
and even the medicare is winning but if
you just submit an entire solution to
the whole problem
then you still want both these things to
win so you'll say let both of them win
so you'll go and vote for drug
enforcement and then you'll also go and
vote for medicare
i agree
really expensive things i want and i
can't get both of those and medicare
and i know medicare is going to win
anyway that i would vote for the thing
is
when i describe this snapshot what do
you think there's something
under the law and the thing that stable
another rug is i said assume you can
vote for things
fractionally so the whole knapsack
voting problem becomes
np hard when you are when you either
choose an entire thing or not use an
entire thing
so i'm assuming that you can have
continuous choices
so i'm assuming that you can choose
things fractionally so what would happen
then
so if if there's only two million
dollars and this costs 1.5
and what you would prefer to do is to
spend 1.5 million here and half a
million here
that's exactly what you will vote for
you say let me vote for the
for 1.5 million for drug enforcement and
then the remaining half a million you
still have to park somewhere
this one you hate so there's no way
you're going to vote for this and so
medicare is what you really want to win
so you'll vote you'll put half a million
of that in medicare
so that's the theorem so
but a theorem is very delicate is is it
it only works
if you if you are asked to give an
entire solution of the whole knapsack
problem
if there's a mismatch for example the
entire budget is 10 million
and i tell you well why didn't you tell
me how to spend 5 million of this money
then the week strategy improvements goes
away
because then what is exactly what you're
saying happens if i say
the entire budget is 10 million why
don't you tell me how to spend 20
million then again the strategy
improvements goes away
so it only works it only works if you if
you're asked to solve exactly the
knapsack problem
that the that the system is trying to
solve
and you also get uh strategy proofness
if instead of just asking so this thing
which which i showed before where you
ask people to compare two things
that unfortunately is not weakly
strategy proof but if you ask users to
choose two projects to compare so you
tell them
you choose these two projects you want
to compare and then compare them
so an example would be you go to a
committee meeting and something's
happening and you say no i don't want
that thing to win
but i want this thing to win instead so
if if you ask users to choose which two
budgets to compare then this thing
becomes weekly strategy proof
and so the big open problem here is that
while i said that we're going to do
we're going to get a weak strategy
proofness
for an individual we didn't make any
claims about
this optimal this ranking that we get
also somehow approximating societal
value
and so so that's going to be like the
next part of the talk
so this part of the talk is sort of very
it's very practical in the sense that
the next goal for us in participatory
budgeting in our platforms is to
convince a city
to go all digital to not have a paper
ballot if they don't have a paper ballot
then we can design the digital ballot
the way we want to design it
and then we can really sort of get away
from approval voting
the reason to do approval voting is
because anything else is very hard to do
with a paper ballot
on a paper ballot you can say go and
choose four things on a paper but you
can't go and can't ask people to say go
and choose
whatever you want but it has to add up
to no more than a million dollars i mean
they're going to just
sit there with a calculator and never
get done
so so i think once we go away from a
paper ballot that's our next goal and
we're getting some good traction with
some cities some
cities at least on a pilot if there's no
paper ballot there's just our system
that you can design the way we like
we really and so these kinds of these
kinds of theorems are really sort of
effective in the sense that we we are
proving them because we need to
understand how to design the system
what i'm describing next is a bit more
hypothetical
so this would be a good time what time
should i start
five past so two o'clock okay
i'm not sure if there's any slides does
anyone have any questions
you're welcome i'm sure everyone will be
very disappointed if you uh
so the next thing is uh so the next
thing so the next thing we want to
understand is how to do large scale
decision making
by a small group interaction
and so here our goal indeed is to
maximize some sort of societal value
so the objective is going to be to find
something which is
in some sense good for the whole society
so this is a famous example run by
francis galton
he went to a fair and he asked people to
guess the weight of an
aux and everyone sort of came up with
their own estimates
and it turned out the median of the
estimates was actually
uh pretty close to the actual actual
vote
actual weight of the aux and so he wrote
a nice paper
called vox popular and he somehow the
inference that he do is that the median
of a bunch of opinions is actually a
good reflection
of what's optimum or what's
what the society should do and the
reason is because the mean is very
susceptible to outliers
whereas the median is not this is a
successful outlier if an outlier you can
move wherever you want and the median
will not change
that they weren't talking to each other
this is important about that that result
if if
if you asked us to weigh the aux we
would be horrible at it
in fact the only time i've been able to
get this to work recently is getting a
bunch of faculty to guess like the
flight time between two places in the
united states
they spend so much time in the air
you've actually done this
yeah yeah like guess guess how many
jelly beans are in the jar
i've never gotten a class to do this
very well because we're just
we're not built to reason that way very
well and
the the property that this one that was
remarkable was that the median was
more accurate than the closest guess i
see
and that's not not the case with like
the jelly bean guessing uh but
was the case i think the flights maybe
it's it's it's an interesting how is the
immediate question
that was so yeah galton actually studied
both the average and the median and i
think
it published it differently in different
yes i think that the media was better
than the mean
other than the mean okay that makes more
sense yeah because it should be
the closest guess should always be as
good or better than the media
votes yeah
some weird education but yeah
so the question is can you do this to
more complex things so the aux is like a
nice number
the jelly beans are a nice number but
how how would you do it to more complex
decisions
like for example was the ideal way to
regulate off-road traffic
and you can still imagine that people
still have
you can imagine that these opinions
still lie in some space they may not lie
on a line
let's assume these opinions lie in some
abstract space
and so you can still define the median
and the generalized median
is called the geometric median or the
one median i just
you just call it the median is the point
in a space
which minimizes the sum of the distances
from the point to everybody else
so just like the mean
minimizes some of the squares of the
distances from that point everybody else
you know when the median is just
something which minimizes the sum of the
distances from that point everybody else
and and the reason they call it the
generalized median is because that's
exactly
that in one dimension the two
differences exactly coincide
so in this case for example let's
imagine that our opinions are structured
on a tree
and like i said this part is sort of
more hypothetical
so it's not going to be people voting in
chicago on budgets it's going to be like
abstract entities where their opinion
spaces form a tree and or they
they're spaced on a grid we're trying to
aggregate them
so let's assume that these these blobs
here are actually people
and and they and where i've placed them
on this tree depends on where their
opinion lies on the tree
let's assume everyone's opinion is a
point on a tree
in this case this guy would end up being
the median
okay so the median is generally well
defined in all spaces on a tree is
particularly easy
on a tree the median is sort of like
uh
uh is a medium is just this node which
is sort of half the people on this side
and have the people on that side
so imagine you have a binary
classification you have many many many
cases
and you could imagine that the biggest
thing for you for people to decide
is whether to hire in systems or in
theory
people who want to hire in systems might
want to hire in networking or in
uh i'm sure it's a faculty search season
so i apologize for the example
people who want to hire in systems
are going to either hire a security
person or a networking person
people don't have a security person
might want to hire someone who does
uh security someone who's mobile
security versus someone who does
enterprise security
and then you'll have a similar chain on
theory so whenever these spaces which
are going these preference spaces are
getting
going to get partitioned finer and final
there's a higher level distinction
and then within these two like between
democrats and republicans when
republicans are mainstream republicans
and tea party republicans
and then tea party republicans they're
like people of this type versus that
type
in that case there's no single candidate
that instantiates that idea
you could you could actually have yeah
there could be yeah that's right
so you could actually you could actually
have a tree which is sort of more like a
yeah would be abstract notes which don't
actually instantiate an idea that's
correct
in this particular example but that
doesn't mean there couldn't be another
example there could be another person
which says no let's just hire
an assistant the best systems guy it
doesn't matter which area they come from
the tree itself kind of kind of like
structuring the void itself because
because by saying that like the question
is the goal is to extract the median
without constructing the tree
so i think that therefore so this is
this is this is so we are assuming that
opinions come from some space we might
assume that opinions come on a tree
but the process that we're going to
describe doesn't use the tree doesn't no
one has to actually specify the tree
explicitly
and the theorems that we described might
be true only if the opinions come from a
tree
but the process we could run on anything
it might not give you desirable results
because our theorems wouldn't hold
or maybe it might give you desirable
results
we cannot claim and give you desirable
does it make sense that that's the whole
point if someone already knew the tree
then there's nothing to do
with this face painting all right
if everyone to a is
it's nice to upgrade as long as every
point in the grid is filled
if you have a grid with holes then it
doesn't realize so it generates like any
any multi-dimensional grid any hypercube
anything which is called the
tessellation of the hypercube
not tessellation retraction of the
hypercube so generalize this to a big
class which i'm going to describe
but you can't have holes so it won't
generalize to this case which
michael was concerned about this hole in
the middle
and the idea here is we want we want so
this is like a complex problem now so
you want to we need to go beyond voting
and the idea here is that people can do
more than just compare proposals
they can say things like what proposal
is closest to x and between y and z
that's the kind of thing you can sort of
expect someone to make
like i i want to reconcile like i'm max
so i want to be as close to where i want
to be but i know that i have to
reconcile what
uh you say and what he says because i
have to somehow carry the two of you
along with me so i have to find i have
to find this thing you sort of like
close to some sort of an average of what
you're saying some sort of
average of what you're saying but it's
closest to what i want
that's the kind of thing that happens
all the time in committees so let's
assume you can have things like this as
a magic box what proposal is closest to
x in between y and z
you can have other things as a magic box
and so the question is
can you identify a magic box like this
thing will be great if you have and see
what you can do
uh and so the magic box that we are
going to assume is that triads can
identify that one median
we're going to assume that we know where
people's opinions lie
and we're not going to assume that we
know the structure we're not even
going to assume that people know their
structure we don't even know how people
can place their opinions on our space
we're going to assume that given that
triags can identify they're 1 million
if i just give you three people they can
together they might not decide to they
might
i'm not saying they'll they'll want to
do it i'm saying there's some way for
them to identify their own media
so i'm going to assume so this is an
example of a reduction i remember doing
lunch today someone was mentioning it'll
be good to have
reductions the second example of
reduction i'm saying
suppose you could do this what could you
do on top
and so we're going to define this thing
called triadic consensus and it's going
to look a bit complicated but the basic
idea is the following we put three
people in a room
uh and we are and we ask in the very
simplest
i'm going to show you something more
complex in the very simplest
instantiation we put three people in a
room let's say xy and z
we ask x do you like y better or z
better we ask why do you like x better
or z better
we are z do you like x better or why
better if one person gets two words we
say yeah you are the winner
if nobody gets two words we'll say well
the three of you can't agree among
yourselves
you're probably like one of those people
who are going to just like love to
disagree they're kicking all three of
you out of disks
so that's that's a very that's a very
simple way in which you would do it in
practice
and you would hope that over time you'll
have like a bunch of centrist people and
ultimately some winner will emerge
but what i'm going to describe is going
to be a more complex process because i
ultimately want to prove a theorem about
it
so imagine that this is room think of it
like caucusing so a lot of
a lot of primaries for example happen
via caucuses this room
there are all these people and we want
to somehow aggregate their opinion
and so we'll take them three by three
and we'll take these three and we say
well why don't you tell us what your one
median is
and we are assuming they can somehow
figure out that 1 million and they'll
say well
they don't really know what tree they
are on but somehow suppose magically
they can figure out their one median
we're going to take all three of them
out we're going to take this person
who's a 1 million
and we'll give this person four words
so we'll say by the way you are the one
median of this triad
it means you are like a guy who's
actually able to have compromised
positions
we're going to give you you have one
more already because there's already one
of you
we're going to make three more copies of
you and give you four words
then we're going to pick three more
people keep repeating the process
and at some point this box will be
of a single color and when this box of a
single color that's when we'll say well
we are done we have consensus
does it make sense the process i was
describing before was a bit more
intuitive you asked three people and say
ask ex to vote on y and z why do what
are my x and x and z zero what among x
and y if one person gets towards this
stay otherwise they get kicked out
this process is a bit more it's a bit
more convoluted
but not too convoluted the idea is you
put three people in a room you ask them
to come up with
one median you take all their votes and
put them on the median
and then you keep and then you proceed
now but
putting them on the median means that
someone has next time you draw a ball
someone has to be able to represent that
ball so which is why it's important that
there are no holes when they come up
with a median the median is actually a
position which is held by somebody
so the winner is the remaining color and
so here's a
here's an example imagine that your
opinions lie on a binary tree
of depth a million okay and so the
question is
if i run this process and i want some
very high probability that the winner is
chosen from the top d levels
would i get d equal to 500 000 so d
equal to 500 000 is roughly a square
root of the population
because it's exponential if i take half
the levels i get a square root of the
population
d equal to 1000 which is even smaller d
equal to 20 which is more like the log
of the height
which is an exponentially small fraction
of the population or d equal to two yeah
like the
the the top and the bottom are they're
just for distraction okay i'm really
asking you to choose among b and c
so the question is at what level would
the winner show up
yeah ultimately there'll be only one
color left and with
and i want to have a very high
confidence saying that this this winner
is going to be from the top d levels
because that's the median for this
binary tree is the guy at the top
and so at what level will i be able to
say confidently that the winner is from
the top d level
the answer is actually two even though i
said it's not a valid answer
you're guaranteed almost suddenly with
very high probability
that when you run this triadic process
the winner is either going to be the
median or the two
get two children of the median and
the party that anyone else will emerge
as the winner is financially small so
you'll get a really
really good approximation of the median
so it doesn't seem like the process i
was describing seemed very very loose
but it actually has this very strong
property
if you have a square grid and you run
this process on the square grid
and the grid is a million and a million
wide then with 99
probability the winner is in i can't
play the same trick again
and so i guess you know that the answer
is going to be d equal to 3.
if you have a million by million grid
and you run this process with 99
probably the winner is going to be in
the center three by three square
so this this process even though it
looks very bizarre has some very strong
properties
in general for any median graph so
median graph is any graph where any
three you know nodes have a unique
medium
trading consensus finds a 1 plus order
of square root log n over square root
and approximate 1 median in order n log
n 3 x
so our triad is like how many how many
of these distance need to make so you
need to do
n log n which means on an average a
person is involved in log entry ads
of course the winner is involved in far
far more because the winner just keeps
accumulating all the balls
but on an average a user is involved in
log n triads which is vanishing which is
very small
and you find a one plus a smaller one
approximate one million
and so that's about as good as you could
get right i mean it's not like one plus
epsilon it's not like two
it's one plus smaller one
this is uh not voting
you're just computing a median in this
sense is this a particularly good bound
or can you do a lot
if you know the entire space
um i didn't think i went that way i have
a hard time believing that
you could do much better on a number
line you can do better than the best
on a line you can do it in time one
order
on a tree i think you might be able to
i'll never think about you might we'll
do it in order and
all right
i don't know about rn but we're looking
very specifically at these grids which
are with the no holes
on a grid you can do it in time ordering
because the median on the grid
is the median is the coordinate wise
median
so you also do it there
so maybe maybe you're losing login
because you're running this bizarre uh
scheme but what you're getting in return
is you never actually have to know
what the spaces and then the
participants never need to know all
these places
they don't ever need to sell them even
they don't need to articulate their
problem with their spare their position
in a very quantitative way so for
example in voting nafta voting you
lay out your words is a very
quantitative well-defined thing it could
just be an abstract opinion that you're
expressing
as long as i can find the one median of
three people i'm okay
and a median graph is something where
for any three nodes
a unique median exists so trees of the
property
grids of that property hide the q as a
property a bunch of graphs of that
property
but anything that has a property this
this thing would work
now is this reasonable so we said
suppose that we asked to find that one
median that was the basis for all this
is that reasonable and is that going to
somehow be incentive compatible maybe
they can but will they
will they just lie and do something else
and so so what we show is another magic
box which is inside this one median
magic box
which lets you compute the 1 million and
that is the box
which is the following what proposal is
closest to x
and between y and z
so think about the person who's asking
this question is actually x
okay so x is me i i want something close
to me
i want to be i have to be able to acc
understand
that if the two of you are i'm in a
triad with the two of you
everybody will understand what's the
position which is very close to my
position
but somehow in the middle of what you
guys want and
if i can answer if i if i have that
magic box if i can make that judgment
then the computing the 1 million reduces
to this specific magic box
and in particular it reduces this magic
box
in a way in which truth telling becomes
a nash equilibrium
so not only will you be able to compute
the 1 median
we will compute the 1 median in a way in
which truth telling is a nash
equilibrium
if everyone else is telling the truth
you have no incentive to lie and in
particular it's not just the nash
equivalent for coming in the one median
was nash equivalent for the entire game
for the entire the multi-period
extensive form strategic game this is a
nash equilibrium
so this is a very powerful property
right but of course i mean
the like all powerful properties it
comes with a caviar and the caviar
has to be a medium gap and the medium
graph cannot have any holes
so it has to be like a fully organizer
can you do it with two people so we said
okay let's use a triad could you have
done it with two people
so you can imagine instead of putting
three people there right you're taking
two people
and these two people are somehow
implementing there's some magic boxes
these two people can do
and based on that you're going to do
something you're going to find something
you want to put it back
we want to do exactly what we did with
triathlon do it with two people
and here we can prove that uh
no reasonable pairwise magic box can
find an approximate one million million
miles
so you need at least three so you
basically need this thing so
intuitively it makes sense you need this
kind of a check on the outlier
like x is voting among y and z z voting
one y and x y is voting over x and z
among the among the triad that access is
sort of like a check on the outlier
and so you need that and if you just
pair wise comparisons
if you have just a pair and i'm here and
then you are there there's no notion of
even trying to figure out what an
outlier means
i'm here and you are there and these are
the only two things in the world right
so
so you can actually show that no
pairwise
process will actually have the same
property but the triadic process will
and this is a bit hypothetical because
we we
um we don't really have a system which
sort of
where we are confident people will have
their opinions on a medium graph and
will play this game
but somehow our goal is to first get the
previous kinds of things that i was
mentioning
about knapsack voting into real
deployments
try to play around with things like this
and the grading consensus game that i
described before
on a more theoretical level do
experiments in class maybe in one of
your classes
and then ultimately maybe hopefully
these kinds of ideas will also find
their way into practice
thank you
you're sort of assuming there's this big
rn
space in which our opinions lie
um i guess regardless um
what's surprising in a sense about what
you're suggesting is that through these
paralyzed solicitations or triad
elicitations you're
in a sense recovering that space uh at
least enough to determine a winner
there's a medium yes um
i'm trying to chew through whether
people's opinions
are amenable to that kind of
formalization where like there's these
weird folds and like inconsistencies and
like discontinuities in our opinions
that would make this kind of thing very
difficult
to project onto a grid the first thing
that i'm describing
that's very easy to do is you put three
people in a room and ask them to vote
for each other
and that we actually tested so not not
in any scale not in anything like which
you would think of as testing but
testing is like a backup and you
couldn't have a backup of the envelope
calculation
we got eight triads and we put
in each read we put either two democrats
in a republican or two republicans and
democrats
and we ask them to come up with a full
federal budget
and then we ask the democrat we ask each
of them to vote among the other two
without telling them who's the democrat
who's a republican
and i think in a majority of our triads
the minority guy one
and then we and then we took these uh
these winners and we put them against
each other and we asked them
if we gave you enough time do you think
you the two of you could solve the
consensus problem for the budget and
they said yes
so i don't quite so it's not um
somehow it also reflects our training
right so we
are more used to proving this theorem
and on the system side
we have it's been hard to conceive of an
experiment
that would do it and part of the reason
also is that these experiments take
effort
and we already are doing these
deployments in cities
so it's partly also just a matter of uh
finding a
couple of willing people who are willing
to think through what an experiment with
this kind of a theory would look like
and actually do it at scale but 10 12
percent experiments these things work
very well
okay yeah i'm just for me
sorry you can jump in a second uh i was
just wondering uh if you're
coming to this medium opinion uh
will it just make like the people that
are really close to it happy
and the majority not as happy you know
what
would it be so i think there's a
difference between personalization and
democracy so in a separate life
i do a lot of research on
personalization but here you have to
come with a single decision
so if you have to come with a single
decision people are going to be unhappy
and in a way the way the median is
defined
a median is defined precisely to
minimize the total amount of unhappiness
so you think of the median the median is
the point which if you choose a median
and if you think of this distance so i
was calling the distance is very
abstract
let's think of it as my unhappiness my
frustration
so the distance between x and xj says
that if my my opinion is x
and those stupid voters out there go and
vote for xj how happy am i going to be
that's exactly what you mean by distance
so in a way the media so in in democracy
there's no way to eliminate that
unhappiness
and the median is precisely the point
which minimizes the sum of the
unhappiness
there are some things maybe to get this
a little more precise
where i feel like a lot of people will
attach infinite unhappiness to them
um so like i think i feel like a lot of
the rhetoric in politics is basically
like
think of pro-life versus pro-choice like
people
attach very very strong opinions to this
but i wonder if it might be possible
through some of the elicitation
techniques you're talking about like
would you give up having a crime system
if you know like where a justice system
entirely
in order to have your way on this like
you might be able to actually project it
back into some sort of continuous space
so our goal for now is to avoid those
kinds of fun
we're it's not an ambition in any way in
the short term
to use this system to solve the arab
israeli conflict
and so yeah but
just so yeah so those things clearly
exist
and it's clear there sort of that
there's no they're not amenable to a
democratic process
and it's not clear what to do one one
thing that we found is often one of the
advantages one of the big advantages of
doing something like this
is that people themselves are forced to
reconcile their own inner differences
now i don't quite know how to put that
in a theorem so maybe that's something
that more like
people like you can think about for
example in san francisco
a majority of san franciscans hold the
following three opinions at the same
time
at the same time one opinion is very
compassionate city
so we don't we don't want any poor
person to lose housing
we are an environmental city so we don't
do any environmental damage or building
new buildings
and we are in the center of this
thriving economy so you want to benefit
from that by having a high big revenue
base and having companies come to san
francisco
and they hold all three of these
opinions at the same time
and you can hold a politician
accountable but it's very hard to go and
hold this random guy on the street
accountable saying are you crazy how can
you always vote
for all three of these things at the
same time whenever initiative comes up
so part of that is so the way i focus
the way i formulate the problem
it seemed very much like we're trying to
do some big
uh opinion aggregation but i think a
bigger contribution might be just to
force people to say this is what i want
to do for the san francisco housing
crisis
and so somehow when people make a budget
so the reason cities love this
is then there's a fixed budget and
people have to come and
express their preferences in that fixed
budget and they can't go and then come
and complain well why didn't that thing
happen because it didn't happen because
they didn't win
and then when because i wanted enough
money